Met Gala is always a fashion piece for
the senses but when it comes to making
that red carpet roar we can always count
on Katy Perry I'm really excited for the
theme which is camp camp is synonymous
with my middle name well actually it is
my middle name Katie camp Perry look on
my birth certificate I um but it's gonna
be really fun I'm basically just gonna
light up the night
[Music]
well Katie kinda already did that when
she wore a light-up dress back in 2010 I
hope I like don't burn up in flames at
the Met Ball but it would be a good way
to go down there's like three thousand
LED lights in the dress oh there's a
trigger in my breath which is probably
not a good idea right now in New York
City to pick out the dress I found
around Styles calm I loved it I mean to
get ready it took me like 45 minutes
maybe newly pregnant Blake Lively as
walk the Met steps nine times but when
it comes to all her amazing fashion well
Blake likes to keep it real every woman
gets up and dresses herself every day
it's not really that extraordinary I
just have more amazing designers to
choose from it galas past Lady Gaga has
done 10 inch platform heels and no pants
shells are done a full kimono so what
can we expect from this year's co-chair
well we're told we'll see lots of
feathers exaggerated ruffles giant
shoulders and corsets I was expecting
that you'd arrive in like an egg or you
know something on the head then did he
tone it down my egg rental you know that
wasn't available I'm so cool ooh and I
really feel like the best thing a woman
can wear is her confidence when you have
confidence the world lives whatever you
sell J Lo's met Caitlyn tile evolution
she started sweet upgraded cutouts then
went bold been tight and showing off her
curves her date this year is of course
Beyonce a rod but her favorite look is
this near
naked dress in 2015
how many fittings that are just going to
you in honor
open that gap oh one I'm putting in my
best dress list does that mean anything
[Music]
[Applause]